hey guys Greg Knuckles here with string
theory calm back with the fifth
installment of our semi daily Q&A series
today's question was is it alright for
lifters to take in sets to take
anti-inflammatories you know to deal
with maybe muscle soreness maybe some
joint discomfort or is that going to
limit muscle growth that's a common idea
a common concern that if you do take
NSAIDs it's going like you know like
ibuprofen that that's going to limit how
well your muscles can respond to
training how much you will grow so just
just kind of to to address this head-on
the evidence is really really mixed here
there are some studies showing that in
said usage while training is going to
limit muscle growth there are also
plenty of studies that show it has no
effect or a very very small effect and
there are actually some studies on
elderly people showing it has a
beneficial effect on muscle growth so to
address this kind of conceptually
training and how you respond to it has a
hormetic curve that's that's kind of the
fancy term for known as bad for you some
is good for you and too much is bad for
you and that that applies to a lot of
things but one of the things that
applies to is the inflammatory response
to training so inflammation acute
inflammation is beneficial for muscle
growth muscle adaptation if inflammation
is too low then muscles don't grow they
don't adapt very well and it and if
inflammation is too high muscles don't
grow and adapt very well so that
probably helps explain why there are
some studies that show that in SEDs are
actually beneficial for elderly people
and muscle
because as you age just baseline levels
of inflammation in your body tend to go
up so maybe by taking an in said
lowering inflammation a little bit helps
your muscles respond a little bit better
to training whereas younger people and
generally healthy people they generally
have lower baseline levels of
inflammation so taking something to
knock inflammation down further may may
not allow inflammation levels to get
high enough to maximize their their
benefit after a training session so and
one more thing to keep in mind here is
that thus far most of the studies done
now our pretty short-term mostly 16
weeks or less which is pretty good for a
training study but doesn't it doesn't
shed too much light on long-term muscle
growth one thing to keep in mind with
insets is one of the other things they
do in your muscles is they decrease
satellite cell activation proliferation
a little bit and this is a big subject
not worth getting into satellite cells
in my own nuclei but essentially past a
certain point
for your muscles to keep getting bigger
and bigger and bigger they need to gain
new my own nuclei that come from
satellite cells which are basically stem
cells that surround your muscle your
muscle fibers and so it very well could
be that a lot of studies that don't show
NSAIDs limiting muscle growth in the
short term it could be that if these
studies lasted years and years the kind
of time span where you'd be reaching
that point where to continue growing you
would need to increase the Myo nuclei
count in your muscles to keep growing it
could be that the the negative effects
of NSAIDs wouldn't show up in the short
term but they may in the long term so
based on the available evidence I think
that it's one of those things that if
you know maybe you just have like an
ache or I mean like a headache or
something like whatever you'd be taking
in sets
if you're only going to be taking them
for you know a couple days a couple
weeks it's probably fine and whatever
effect that they would have on muscle
growth would be small enough that it
wouldn't even be noticeable you know
like take them knock down inflammation
help with pain help with your headache
whatever and then get off of the incense
move on with life but for most people
most of the time I think it's probably
not prudent to stay on incense long term
for muscle growth and also because it's
probably just not a good idea to say on
anti-inflammatories long term anyway if
you need to do that you probably have
bigger problems that need to be squared
away that is the video if you liked it
please like and subscribe and if you
have questions you won't answer ask them
in the comments below and if I like your
question I'll pick it and answer it in
tomorrow's video all right so that's it
guys until next time stay strong stay
slow and yeah hope things are great see
you then